[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all
right we are live i love podcast
watergatewith.net we are here with the
legendary
sir toby
i'm doing really good thank you for
coming it's a pleasure
everything is bigger and better of
course but since the last time we met
we've been at gamescom
not long ago and of course we were
finally able to reveal the release date
which is october 13th we are fine tuning
the game right now
last bits and pieces being uh
tour
exactly and it has made it ready and i
have the latest and greatest for you
here in the las vegas
uh we will play together
again let's go through that so i have
passed wanted path too that it's not you
won't see that in the game it's like
really just
uh the the things that led us to this to
this particular point okay so let's
start with the rat and you're playing
one
exactly
and um i'm your sidekick so you are you
are the one who is pushing the story
forward
you are doing all the decisions you are
the one in charge i'm just helping you
which means it's a we playing split
screen call up um
you can play online with anyone else
however uh the point is that if you hit
a random or whatever like someone
you can't just quit your game and take
all the items so you are always all the
stuff stays with you you're the man in
charge and i'm just hoping yeah so
basically my progression stays with me
absolutely
so just to give you a short
overview of what's happening so we the
last very crew last original crew
stranded on this
trend on this um sci-fi medieval planet
like the alien planet and those ratcans
here are fighting against the guru and
they pull us in into our dragons into a
civil war they want us
each of those sides they want us to help
them but it's up to us be careful
whenever there's a guy who will shoot
you right away
they want uh what they want from us is
let me help them of course but uh the
games
be careful
follow
of el me
i played dustin neon at the road games
and i did so i entered a raffle
for a nintendo switch oh led
that's right a nintendo switch oled
give it away
at 4pm today all you have to do is try
out one of our amazing titles playable
for you right here today in packs
and follow me sir that's good let's do
it but this time we stay close to the
wall here
but they shoot
they're shooting
shoot the tooth
shoot
and the idea is
that we are supposed to like
check out the area and help the rats
they want to invade the city and we our
task was to scout the city and find
general draft
the captain of the redken
well we can see that he's being like
attacked unfairly shooting him in the
back but in the last second he was able
to flee
we have to go back and report to the
reds we saw earlier to god and then we
our task is to go to the city and kill
everyone on site
small steps of course but it's going
forward and that's that's
yeah just can't skip it just skip it
with me just skip through it he's
basically telling us that uh
that the general was running away and
then he wants us to go through the tours
through the city
he wants us to go through the city
and uh to the other side of the city and
actually uh find the general
so we're going to do that right now one
thing i've noticed
is
the question as far as like the next
step that they've kind of had up on the
oh
yeah you lock on the enemy and with r1
you shoot your fireball
all right
wow
careful you have to lock on your
opponent
oh nice shot
oh in the back
okay let's let's say first because
we don't want to spawn in the sewers
again
so these are but these are our same
points exactly exactly yeah we can level
up we can do whatever but you just kind
of skip out of it again because we just
need to save
uh yeah exactly
there's bad guys again be careful
lock it in yeah oh and fire
fire
let's try one thing if you hold this
button you lock to me try that just hold
it hold it hold it hold it a long time
wait a second when i tell you you shoot
a fireball the r1 at me okay let me try
something
i put on the amplifier sheet and now
shoot please
it bounces off of me and it's being
amplified so your fireball is being made
stronger through my shield
it sounds like a like tiny gameplay
thing but the fact what we're trying to
do here is to enhance the co-op
experience so if you push the button
again you unlock from me nice see that's
cool because i was going to say when i
didn't have that lock it was kind of
hard to keep track of you
and now with it
that that helps me stick close to you
because i don't like me inside of you
oh shoot
be careful not to put [ __ ] in the back
oh night shot very good
nice
i like that
bad guys everywhere need to be careful
all right
get that going right here
if you hold r2 you can manually aim
which you don't have to but then
oh this could show a job
so there's no there's no uh mana potion
in the game
so if you push the left uh
you currently have a mana drainer
equipped with l1 and you are a very
strong person you can punch him now and
if you do so you drain the mana of the
energy so this person here will not
attack us hopefully
uh so just try it
yep
and punch and punch and punch and punch
and punch and punch see and you're full
of money
right that will be the way how you we
how you will be able to get them out of
it
okay
engine
launching process last time
here we go
don't forget to do uh either that one or
with our with the
with the bumper thingy
you push this one once always right if
you do so you lock through the enemy it
will be way easier to aim your fireballs
and the hole is used
oh shoot
once
but be careful not to get down
r1 nice
everybody's coming for you
this is strong dude
if you hold it you have to aim which is
a bit of tricky
that's of course that's something that
is still being improved so
that's good for good for dps
oh yeah
so hold r2
i can aim with the oh he's down already
i could act for you
is it like your ambulance garbage you
can you can you can pick me up so the
advantage of you picking me up is that i
will have full health
if i respawn which i can then i will
have just a tiny amount of health and i
have to go walk all the way so again it
should inspire us to play together and
work together and so on
okay so
let's try something different now okay
so we are going we saw all that and if
we decide with the redskins they want us
to
kill the nabaru and go through the city
jump into the sewers open the gate and
then they will go through the city okay
what would have happened if we wouldn't
start with the redken
what would have happened if you signed
with the navarro this is the other
version so that's the same you will see
the same area again but it will play
completely different and that's a big
point
whatever you do in the game every
decision everyone you sign with everyone
you kill everyone every quest you follow
this will have a direct impact on
everything that follows up you are now
the belief fighter
just pick this one so you unstick from
me
i'm the good guy don't worry
i like it it's very lordly
so let's talk to this dude here
just skip to it he wants us to see the
the queen of the navarro so let's go and
check her out
the point is you can see that there's a
different entry to this area it's the
same area but we haven't been here
earlier right at all but it's still the
same level so there's a different entry
point different exit points different
things you have to do
let's go here
talk to that lady there please
left
there
so you see the relationship thing so the
more you do stuff for someone or against
someone it will increase or decrease the
relationship which means that the redken
will attack us or will fight with us and
so on so these actions you do have these
heavy impacts
let's get through that
so down there is now a cut scene that's
the same cutscene we saw earlier right
from another perspective from another
perspective it plays a little bit
different though because earlier
remember there was this dude and he
almost killed the red general and he was
like nah last last attempt and then
what's up
he's actually saying like
i want to fight the champion up here
[Music]
and again some co-op elements which are
really cool
let's go down here
and just because you as a player decided
to go a certain way the game is pretty
short with 15 to 20 hours but the idea
is that you kind of find your way and
then you just replay it to different
mistakes different happy accidents kind
of
see what the other side of the
war uh looks like and so on and it has
to the replayability yes you are first
go in i will no and that's where we came
from
there
yes no the other way around there
i will zap you now you saw that already
on parks east but the zapping is just so
good and we if we're able to get someone
in between of us happening to death
baby jane
absolutely
yes
he's one of the other last horry crew by
the way last original
spaceship tells us crazy sci-fi stuff
not a narrative
yeah
talk to this gentleman here please
by the way earlier we came through here
right through the sewers and now we went
through the map from the other side
and now
you have to go through that
you shall be the champion
of course we
save
before you go
oh there you go
so
now there's whenever you do decisions
you don't have to stick to them you
feel like okay the number maybe you're
not as great as you think or maybe you
want to support them even more really
doesn't matter well it doesn't matter
it's your choice and now the original
says
dude listen to me spare me i'm not a
navarro
so you got a decision and you got
crossroads brother crossroads kill him
i'll let him run away and he corrected
me
so i was going to kill him but he bred
to be so we got him we got a little
we're going to bring him in we're going
first of all
oh we got to let him run away or kill us
i'm going to see what happens i would
not let this man run away call this
creature
i want to see what happens if you show
compassion and mercy
and i will spoil you a little if if you
would have chosen the kill business
then we would actually try to get him to
uh hb0
but then the situation would have
repeated from what we saw earlier we
would have been the person who came
close to him wanted to stab him and he
did the last resort thing and runs away
but now that we support him then we told
him like dude listen
i got you bro
he told us okay
you know what meet me and just meet me
at the mines maybe we can talk so that
would be like the exit strategy now to
eventually get back to the redskins
maybe see what their idea is of the
world and so on and it just shows you
that you played the same area twice but
differently
first placer were completely differently
than the second from one thing i respect
about that probably the pathways right
and seeing how the structure and how the
branches can play out
again we've got the release date just to
remind everyone what's that release date
october 13th on ps5 xbox series xns and
pc
see a guy like me that's terrible at
solo games i can get into this
because i can help
well i sometimes call it a souls like
games for people who are not into souls
likes so
the devs don't like what i say what
about look you cater it's about did i
just say it on camera
he's playing on the micrographic that's
how you get me
an absolute pleasure brother thank you
very much great to see you man we cannot
wait we're excited check this out here
the last or through the original crew
kind of like us
oh
you already know all right
[Music]
you